so this is the master bedroom and uh
these walls they used to be like
white like an asylum so i wanted it to
be softer so i had it painted in
eggshell white guess what
white and eggshell white are exactly the
same color
exactly i thought you said that you were
going to tidy things up
well i shave on you
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
jan has uh
some space issues so i curl up on that
puppy
really cause seems pretty narrow
and short it's actually a lot bigger
than it seems look at this
see he fits perfectly
i finally broke down and bought myself
a plasma tv
check it out i actually hung this on the
wall myself
that's good i want to show you something
a lot of people in the room you need
more space
voila right into the wall wow sometimes
i will just stand here and watch
television for hours
i love it i love this tv
hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick
oh really i'm sorry to hear that man
yeah bullets over broadway was on tv
i came down with a big old diane weast
infection
like yeast
tom i couldn't afford enough premium
carpet to get us to the stage i mean it
was a short walk but it was pretty
luxurious right
okay
everybody smile away
[Music]
i'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing
and i'm putting him down no ronnie only
has three legs
[Music]
run run there's no scares how do i get
to the stage
[Music]
okay
okay what if someone steals a baby what
then do you want me to just sit there
and watch someone take a baby what if
the baby is wearing a bomb then wouldn't
you want him to steal it
i'm trying to picture a scenario in
which somebody plays oh what if it's
baby hitler oh
yeah a very good question tough is it i
think you got to kill that baby hitler
yeah
how would you know that that baby was
going to grow up to be hitler what if
that baby was gonna grow up to be the
exact opposite of hitler
churchill no lance bass interesting
oprah yeah oprah oprah you gotta save
that baby
gotta save it i'm more of an ellen
person
it's fun when she dances anyway what i'm
saying is
don't be adina be a jonah
oh wait you guys what if
it's baby oprah but the person stealing
it is beyonce
speaking of relationships of all all way
shapes and forms
um i was out on a very very hot date
last night with a girl from h.r dwight
really we don't have any girls for me
no that for the sake of this story
and things were getting hot and heavy
yeah and i was about to take her bra
off when she had me fill out six hours
worth of paperwork
like an aids test no
god all right
so let's get this party started let's go
yeah let's get out of here um
guys where are you going just uh pam
show's just getting started
sorry
and now to someone who goes quietly
about their job but
always i need someone the biggest
accounts the busiest bieber award goes
to phyllis
lapin yeah way to go phyllis
nice work per usual this says bushiest
beaver what i told them busiest
idiots it's fine we'll fix it we'll fix
it up
you don't have to display that jake
hurry up starving sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry
i just had to grab my wall
gentlemen
fine i was trying something and it
didn't work i have some very important
news about our favorite mini horse lil
sebastian
he died last night no but we can take
comfort in the fact
that he is in heaven now doing the two
things he loves doing the most
eating carrots and urinating freely when
i walked in this morning and saw the
flag was at half-mast
i thought all right another bureaucrat
ate it
but then i found out it was little
sebastian halfmast is too high
show some damned respect because of all
he's done for the town
we are gonna be holding a small memorial
service for him but
for now i think we should bow our heads
in a moment of silence
[Music]
[Applause]
i got it thank you you put the peeps in
the chili pot and eat them both up you
put the peeps
in the chili pot and add the m m's you
put the peeps
in the chili pot it makes it taste bad
i'm gonna eat all this chili and or
die trying anyone want any i'm just
gonna
put it right down here come on dip your
balls in my chili
scoopy little mittens right in the stew
professor
i can see that you're going through
something but exams are next week
so can you teach us anything all right
nerd wanna learn something i'll teach
you something
i'm gonna teach you the meaning of life
how you like them apples
now jim is going to be the client dwight
you're going to have to sell to him
without being aggressive hostile or
difficult
let's go all right fine
[Music]
hello hello this is dwight schrute from
the dunder mifflin paper company
well that's great because i need paper
excellent then you are in luck because
we are having a limited time offer only
on
everything wow this is my lucky day what
is your name sir
i am bill butlicker really that's your
real
name how dare you my family built this
country by the way
be respectful dwight please oh yes
michael could you hold on one second
that's my other line
what no but i hello yeah
no i'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just going to keep him on the
line forever and not buy anything
okay it's up to you to change his mind
sorry that was a
family emergency oh no what's wrong you
know what that's private
boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr
butt licker as i was saying
we're having a limited a little bit
louder i'm hard of hearing he's hard if
he's an old man
okay as i was saying right now we are
talking louder okay
our prices have never been low you have
to talk louder never been lower
louder son buttocker our prices have
never been lower
hey ron i run
ladies ladies
[Applause]
um
you